come on guys still to come on darcy and
stacy
the coronavirus is spreading everything
changed at the drop of a dying
oh my gosh guys there's nothing look at
my place
the new home georgie's coming tomorrow
oh he's coming tomorrow yeah
honestly i would never lock myself in an
apartment
during quarantine with a guy that i've
only been on a couple dates with
what was he doing in her room and in her
bed and i want to know is there any more
oh now you're going to sit here and act
all innocent like you didn't do anything
wrong
really really every time i try to talk
to you you just
tell me to shut up
this is becoming a very very draining
situation
and i just want to know what happened
keep it simple honey
i am not your honey okay and it's not my
fault
that floyd sugar want to taste my honey
okay
sugar yes how much worse can it get
i like to tell you the truth i wish i
would have known about this sooner
that happening right now
i want to believe him we have too old to
have to worry about
other [ __ ] i don't want to talk about
any more with boss i'm tired from this
i just feel like i don't know enough
about him i need to get to the bottom of
things
i want to build a life i want a future
let's take away
tired of it please
as friends i feel like i need to share
something with you guys
i'm scared there's one thing that's come
to the surface
being a quarantine with georgie i
haven't said anything
to anybody not even you guys
[Music]
you